falls sie die plattform tik tok nicht
kennen sollte da wird beispielsweise so
etwas hochgeladen
ja mir sollte man da definitiv nicht
folgen allerdings gibt es auf dieser
plattform natürlich nicht nur mich der
dort seinen geistigen dünnschiss
hochlädt sondern auch eine menge anderer
leute und ich habe schon zweimal auf
verschiedene tech talks reagiert ja
denen sollte man eigentlich auch er
nicht folgen noch heutigen video meine
damen und herren ihr seht ist bereits im
titel ist bereits im titel eingeblendet
wir stellen heute tickt ochs nach ich
bereue meine tik tok hier gegangen und
bei dieser startseite bekommt man ja
verschiedene sachen einfach zufällig
zugewiesen da habe ich mich einfach mal
ein bisschen durch gegolten habe
insgesamt neun
ich habe insgesamt neun verschiedene
ticker videos rausgesucht wo ich mir
gedacht habe hey die sind entweder cool
oder peinlich oder dumm oder die könnte
ich einfach mal nachmachen bevor wir
allerdings mit dem ersten tag doch video
anfang meine damen und herren da ja
jetzt vor einigen tagen halloween war
habe ich natürlich auch auf meinem
täterprofil dazu ein video gemacht als
ihr euch das ansehen wollte musste beim
tik tok vorbeischauen
er kommt scheißegal ich zeige es euch
einfach
[Musik]
happy halloween ist schon zwei tage her
weil egal daten jedoch nun allerdings
mit dem ersten video was ich mich
irgendwie raus gesucht habe ja ich zeige
es euch einfach mal
[Musik]
dieser moment wenn man hat nichts
besseres zu tun hat als einen tick schon
richtig auf zu leben als ich weiß jetzt
nicht wo hier in der nähe ein schwimmbad
ist sodann freibad wo ich das irgendwie
aufnehmen und nach stellen könnte aber
wir können ja tricksen die bereits
gesagt haben wir hier kein freibad oder
schwimmbad oder so nebenan aber dass
nicht wir haben hier so was haben leute
hier mein nachbar ja ich bin der beste
tik tok user der welt haben wir
allerdings nun direkt auch schon zum
zweiten video was ich rausgesucht habe
das ist nämlich von einer frau von einer
amerikanerin die irgendwie immer so
challenges vorschlägt ja ihr profil
heißt tatsächlich hip hop heidi 88
wahrscheinlich die frau von montana
black 88 jahre genommen auf jeden fall
hat sie in ihrem text video hier eine
challenge sage ich mal vorgeschlagen die
man nach machen sollte deswegen meine
liebe hip hop heidi ich bin großer fan
wird die challenges nachmachen also bei
dem nächsten video hier ist es besonders
übrigens hier
wo habe ich nur dieses kleine pop sein
handy für halten
hierbei geht es darum dass ich irgendwie
mit dem linken arm nur runter mit dem
rechten arm nach oben nach rechts und
nach unten das heißt ich muss erst mal
im stehen machen
er wird sich jetzt hier hinstellen und
mich aufnehmen während ich versuche
diese challenge zu machen wir nehmen da
allerdings nicht diesen heidi ton wie
sie das erklärt sondern unseren
originalen
ja
hat super funktioniert heidi ich will
ehrlich gesagt ich weiter beim einen
misslungenen versuch diese challenge
nachzumachen reden ich weiß nicht ich
könnte ja selber mal zu hause probieren
das ist hardcore schwer also
ich mache mich komplett zum affen ich
zeige euch mal das nächste tickt auf
video
[Musik]
m
ja ich kann das definitiv auch dieses
video wo sich tatsächlich auch wieder
entstehen aufnehmen deswegen hab ich
brauche auch im basketball also so wie
das hier machen machen die erst gegen
die was mit den beiden tanks ist ein
bisschen unser nachmachen die also hin
und her schwarz mit dem ball
also ich werde irgendwann nachts machen
[Musik]
na na na
unna
[Musik]
hat auch hat also wirklich hier auch
wieder klasse geklappt ich meine leute
lasst doch mal ein like da wenn ihr
findet dass ich wirklich der beste tipp
topp mensch der welt benutzt überhaupt
tik tok wirklich halt echt mal
interessieren weil ich hatte mich da
gestern mit rob darüber unterhalten und
er meinte er sieht den sinn dahinter gar
nicht so richtig und ich tatsächlich
eigentlich auch nicht so wirklich ich
mache eigentlich nur so aus spaß wenn
ich überhaupt mal was hochladen dann
eigentlich mehr so parodie lustig machen
mäßig aber es hat geklingelt weil julius
klamotten karmann hier können sie heute
allerdings nicht um klamotten sondern um
tik tok deswegen film ab für das nächste
video wahnsinnig du kannst mich doch
nicht zu erschrecken
diese hätten wir klingen doch morgen der
steuerprüfung der raschen mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit in eine rezession
super da passiert endlich einmal was
außerdem ist der kreis hat das wurde mir
tatsächlich als allererstes auf der
startseite angezeigt ich weiß nicht
warum weil das ist aus dem film
traumschiff surprise
den habe ich früher tatsächlich über
alles geliebt aber das ist einfach nur
quatsch
nach und ich haben uns dass gerade so
ein bisschen angeschaut und es wird
schwierig sie müssen es halt zu zweit
machen deswegen werden wir zusammen vor
die kamera stellen nicht wahnsinnig du
kannst mich dort zu erschrecken
so hektisch wir klingen doch morgen eine
steuerprüfung der raschen mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit in eine rezession
ist doch super da passiert endlich
einmal was also dem was der kreis hat
super synchronisation luca du bist mein
lieblings tik tok user als faul am
nächsten video erklärt uns ein mädchen
der wie man schaffe letzten haute
schaffen
[Musik]
ok also sie hat uns einen move
beigebracht und am ende auch wirklich
richtig sage ich mal den mut angetan ist
das heißt herr luca its your turn wie
gesagt ich bring euch jetzt staffeln bei
[Musik]
beim tutorial sah das ganze noch ganz
gut aus aber danach habe ich echt
komplett verpackt in der tat das nächste
video sind zwei japaner die mit tanzen
in der öffentlichkeit und die als ich
zeige ich möchte ich zeige es euch
erstmal
[Musik]
das wird jetzt spannend
ich bin kein hoch als nächste talk video
was ich mir ausgesucht haben könnte sehr
verstörend wir können aber seht einfach
selbst
ich bin jung ich bin ganz ich bin sexy
habe
warum und warum muss ich das jetzt
nachbarin also das ist jetzt natürlich
sehr kraft nachzustellen
wir wollen uns erst mal eine brille und
gummibänder a a
ich bin jung ich bin geil ich bin sexy
habe also wirklich leute lasst den
daumen hoch da wirklich echt ich mache
mich hier so zum affen
das ist hier mein material für fanpages
für 1000 jahre und da ich mich hier so
zum affen machen kommen wir auch nun
schon zum letzten video was ich mir
ausgesucht habe wieder eine person aus
amerika bzw aus dem englischsprachigen
raum und ja film ab
b
das könnte tatsächlich sonntags talk
video sein was sich selbst auch auf
meinem profil hochladen also irgendwie
interessant lustig aber irgendwie auch
dumm und ja von daher lokal und juni lag
bei dem wir machen das so dass jude sich
quasi team er filmt mit unserer videos
[Musik]
das hier logic ist somit ein peinliches
video was ich je hochgeladen habe von
daher will ich an dieser stelle das
heutige video jetzt auch beenden meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hat wie wir diese tecdax nachgestellt
haben und das ganze eventuell nochmal
haben wollt dann lasst 60.000 leichter
freunde
es ist eine enorme riesige zahl das weiß
ich selbst ich bezweifle auch dass sie
das schaffen werden aber ich saß echt
lang an diesem video an der recherche
produktion
ihr wisst was ich meine
ich habe ja
[Musik]